Charles Dickens was the most famous
writer in the English language during
the 19th century and one of the
best-selling authors of all time he can
seem remote the frock coat the velvet
collar the fishtail beard the bowtie but
he has a lot to say to us today and
that's because he had a remarkable
ambition he believed that writing could
play a big role in fixing the problems
of the world
Dickens didn't just write from the very
beginning there were signs of a great
showman as a child he loved putting on
plays in the family kitchen and singing
songs standing on a table in the local
pub before radio or television going to
hear Dickens giving a reading was to
experience an exceptional showman often
to the dismay of later literary friends
entertainment remained at the heart of
what Dickens was up to he was always
hoping to get us interested in some
pretty serious things the evils of an
industrializing society the working
conditions in factories child labor
vicious social snobbery the maddening
inefficiencies of government bureaucracy
in theory we recognized that these and
their modern versions are pretty worthy
themes but if we're honest with
ourselves we admit that they don't sound
very inviting as things to read about in
a novel in bed or at the airport Dickens
is genius was to discover that the big
ambitions to educate his society about
its failings didn't have to be opposed
to what his critics called fun racy
plots a chatty style clownish characters
weepy moments and happy endings he
rejected the idea that we have to make a
fatal choice between being worthy but
dull or popular but shallow Dickens set
out to educate via entertaining because
he so well understood how easy it is for
us individually and collectively to
resist certain tricky but important
lessons Dickens is significant because
he was working out for his own time how
to do something that's crucial for ours
how to be seductive about serious things
char's Dickens was born in Portsmouth in
February 1812 his father was a clerk in
the Navy office they had to constantly
move about to follow his different
appointments it was a genteel life at
first but there were always money
troubles looming when he was only 10
Dickens had to leave school because his
parents could no longer afford the
modest fees he was sent to work in
London at a blacking factory where they
made polish for giving a dark Sheen much
admired at the time two metal surfaces
it was a grim experience young Dickens
hated the fumes and numbing speed with
which he had to carry out repetitive
tasks the people he worked around were
bullying and sinister then his father
was arrested for debt at that time
debtors could be confined to prison
along with their dependents by their
creditors until they were able to start
paying off what they owed so the whole
family moved into the squalid Marshal
sea prison except young Dickens who
lodged nearby and continued with his
horrible job part of the continuing
popular affection for Dickens comes from
his very strong sense of the
precariousness of life and his deep
compassion for those who are its victims
when Dickens his life improved in his
early 20s he discovered that he was an
outstandingly brilliant journalist
Dickens was very good at remembering his
own suffering and he used it in a very
clever way he always put really nice
characters into the awful places of
Victorian England the blacking factory
is described in David Copperfield
through the eyes of young David who is
sensitive intelligent and charming
David is the reader when young or the
reader son or nephew Dickens is saying
imagine someone like you or someone you
like was in somewhere like that when he
writes about poor houses which were
local forced labour camps for people
unable to support themselves Dickon
sends in little Oliver Twist who
actually belongs to a well-to-do family
from whom he's been separated by a
series of tragic accidents Oliver is not
typical at all of the people who ended
up in poor houses but he's there so that
his readers who at that time would
generally be quite prosperous could
think what if this were me on one
occasion when Dickens shows us the
miseries of a debtor prison it's in the
company of a lovable buffoon a muddled
but very sweet and well
man call mr. micawber the background
protective assumption that only rather
shady types could end up here is
punctured Dickens was working with a key
assumption of course everyone knew
already that there were poor houses
horrible working conditions and debtors
prison these were obvious facts of early
19th century life in England the point
was that comfortable people the kind of
people who had the power to change
things generally didn't feel much sense
of urgency they didn't feel personally
connected to the problems so Dickens
used his own experience to get people to
feel interested in and sympathetic to
the plight of others that they'd
normally have been emotionally very
distance from he didn't say look how
awful it is for them he said here's what
it would be like for you in an ideal
world we perhaps care equally about
everyone but in reality our concern is
much more readily directed towards the
misfortunes of people we know and find
likeable so if like Dickens your project
is to draw attention to a failure in the
system it's a very good strategy to
follow the method he was using get us to
like the people who are having a hard
time and then and only then can we start
to feel engaged
the other thing that Dickens did to keep
us on board with his high-minded vision
of social reform was to keep on showing
how well he understood the cozy pleasing
enjoyable things of life he desperately
didn't want the big causes to come
across as meaning you couldn't keep on
liking all the sweet comforts of life so
Dickens was particularly good at evoking
the pleasures of home in one of his
novels he takes us to the house of a
lovable old eccentric whose refashioned
his small suburban house as a miniature
Castle complete with a tiny drawbridge
that can be pulled up by lengths of
twine to keep the wild world at bay
Dickens loved picnics games of cricket
in the park going shopping for a new tie
doughnuts
sitting by the fire having friends round
for dinner warm blankets and going on
holiday being a caring and good person
he is saying doesn't mean disdaining the
ordinary small pleasures this is a key
element in Dickens's general strategy he
knows it's going to be hard to get
people to think about difficult things
if you don't start from a deep
recognition of what we are already like
otherwise you can come across as cold
and a bit obsessive Dickens took the
practical business side of writing very
seriously he was immensely productive he
churned out books and he was deeply
concerned about copyright laws sales
figures and profit margins but Dickens
didn't simply want to sell a lot of
novels he wanted to change things in the
world but he knew perfectly well that a
book wouldn't have an effect unless it
was in wide circulation unless the
business side was going well his writing
draws attention to many things that were
going wrong the poor law the dreadful
state of schools rampant nepotism and
harsh working conditions but he wasn't
trying to advocate specific schemes of
reform if you'd asked Dickens what
exactly the government should do to
improve the conditions in factories or
what a better legal system would look
like he wouldn't have had a carefully
worked out alternative policy to hand
what he was doing was shaping the
climate a feeling and opinion which
makes it much easier for people trying
to get an act through Parliament raise
funds or make local improvements others
can much more readily see the point of
political action once the issues have
moved up the mental agenda and feel
close to us emotionally
Dickens was very interested in trying to
help the world and hugely sensitive to
the sufferings of others but closer to
home things didn't work out so well he
wasn't a good husband or father he got
married in 1837 when he was in his
mid-20s - Catherine Hogarth and they had
ten children together eight of whom
survived into adulthood but Dickens
increasingly found her dull and passive
and when he was in his mid-40s he fell
in love with a 19-year old actress Ellen
Ternan
he couldn't get divorced it was
completely taboo for a major public
figure to take such a step so they
separated his wife left after 20 years
together and they never saw each other
again Dickens was unimpressed by all of
his children whom he regarded as idle
and ever ready to sponge off him they
were prone to drinking too much into
gambling Dickens is a painful reminder
of the terrible conflicts that can arise
between different kinds of devotion
Dickens was immensely painstaking with
his work he'd stay up as late as needed
he'd think of it first thing in the
morning he'd exhaust himself yet around
his children and his wife he was
plodding conventional and often coldly
detached we could blame him and say he
should have been a better partner and
father all we could feel a touch of pity
for the horrible limitations of our
nature which can make it hard for us to
be very good at two very different kinds
of things at the same time and hopefully
a little of this pity can extend to
ourselves since we are the ones who now
actually need it on the 8th of June 1870
when he was 58 Dickens died at home
after his usual intense day's work he
was at the early stages of his 15th
novel The Guardian published an obituary
the next day wherever the English
language is spoken the intelligence we
published this morning of the decease of
mr. Charles Dickens will be received
with feelings of deep regret early last
night it became known that the
distinguished novelists had been seized
with paralysis at his residence
gadshill Kent Dickens his power doesn't
lie just in the particular things he
wrote what's even more impressive is the
bigger idea to which he was loyal all
his life that the task of writing an art
more generally is to make goodness
attractive to make it easier and more
bearable for us to learn uncomfortable
lessons and to broaden our sympathies by
helping us to identify with people whose
outward lives may be unlike ours but
whose inner lives are not unsimilar
you